passons la page politique civis 20
montel bonsoir vous êtes élu depuis 2008
à villepreux ancienne adjointe au maire
sortant stéphane mirambeau et depuis
quelques semaines en campagne dans le
cadre de ces élections municipales 2020
tête de liste tous pour villepreux
ce sera une liste sans étiquette sans
investiture sans soutien c'est le choix
que vous avez fait tout à fait c'est un
choix que nous avons fait moi ainsi que
mes colistiers sans étiquette c'est à
dire que nous n'avons aucun soutien
d'aucun parti politique et c'est ça leur
est le réel sujet du sans étiquette mais
cette collaboratrice de gérard larcher
président de l ère du sénat toute
transparence n'a pas de soutien viendra
pas soutenir votre campagne n'aurait pas
fait parce que on estime que ce soit moi
je m'en prenais s'cusez moi et mes
colistiers que le soutien dont nous
avons besoin son soutien des villes
rosien et pas de parti politique et
j'entends la sueur des élections
municipales ça prend vraiment du sens
ces propos l'art vraiment du sens donc
non politisée une liste aux municipales
comme la nôtre sur une ville comme
villepreux je pense que c'est un non
sens je pense que les villes projets
n'ont pas besoin de ça et n'ont pas
besoin de soutien partis politiques
s'ils aiment ils ont besoin même de
linverse ils ont besoin du soutien de
leur maire et nous on a besoin de leur
soutien c'est ça l'essentiel
alors qui composent cette liste je les
préciser vous êtes ancienne adjointe au
maire aujourd'hui donc vous construisez
cette liste sans étiquette il ya des
anciens aux élus qui vous ont rejoint
des nouveaux des nouveaux aussi le plus
jeune a 18 ans a fait de bien renseigner
complètement
donc c'est une liste très mixte un très
très mélangé il ya toutes les origines
il ya tous les âges ca de 18 ans à
retraités et jeunes retraités en passant
par tous les âges différents milieux
sociaux face est en fait une liste qui
représente la ville c'est une liste où
on va retrouver des personnes dans tous
les quartiers donc tous les quartiers
sont représentées toutes les tous des
styles de vie sont représentés on va
retrouver vivre dans cette liste et
c'est ça c'est ça l'objectif
l'unique objectif c'était ça je pense ou
même la question dans quel état d'esprit
êtes vous aujourd'hui puisque on leur
dit vous êtes une ancienne adjointe au
maire vous avez
vu vos délégations retirer juste avant
l'été dans un contexte assez difficile
je rappelle qu'il ya toujours une plante
en instruction actuellement pour
harcèlement sexuel envers à stéphane
mirambeau le maire sortant qui lui aussi
va se représenter
aujourd'hui vous vous êtes dans quel
état d'esprit revanchard quelques pas ou
pas du tout alors d'abord c'est pas du
tout mon tempérament d'être revancharde
je n'ai jamais été gpac afin de
rancunier par contre quand on me fait du
mal je suis pas amnésiques
ça c'est le premier point donc non
revanchard
absolument pas le l'histoire des
plaintes je veux même pas en entendre
parler sur le sujet n'était pas là
c'était par rapport au retrait des
délégations me sens ok 160 prévenir et
sans rien me dire
donc c'était une sacrée surprise at été
bien aidé par un certain nombre d'élus
qui étaient autour de lui qu'il
soutenait à l'époque on va pas revenir
là dessus je me suis expliqué au conseil
municipal du 27 24 septembre
donc là tu tout a été dit donc je
préfère fermer le fermer le livre c'est
beaucoup plus simple et quand vous dites
tel état d'esprit
non je suis dans un très bon état
d'esprit qui nous à l'état d'esprit où
je vais de l'avant donc le livre il est
fermé chants touré de gens bienveillants
ça fait beaucoup de bien et je veille à
ce que cette bienveillance le reste est
donc au contraire un très bon état
d'esprit pour aller avec une feuille de
route jusqu'au mois de mars avec
confiance de plus en plus dans les
villes prodia qui feront le bon choix
on va parler de vos propositions dès les
premières propositions le programme bien
évidemment comme pour l'ensemble des
candidats qui passent en plateau
actuellement est encore en cours
d'élaboration le scrutin a lieu le 15
mars mais comme vous faites partie
malgré tout la majorité sortante
est-ce que vous assurer une partie de ce
bilan alors c'est une très bonne
question je remercie je ride bien
évidemment quand on a été élu pendant
quasiment 12 ans dans la majorité ça
serait une grave erreur de dire non je
fais un reset et jeux non non bien
évidemment que le bilan m'appartient
aussi je suis né du sortant je suis la
seule tête de liste la sep du ski et
sortons puisque aux dernières
informations le merde se présentera pas
en tant que tête de liste
ça c'était la nouveauté d'hier donc donc
du coup je suis leur évolue vite
puisqu'ils savent encore rien à faire
mais bon côté il faut suivre je vous
conseille d'aller sur les réseaux
sociaux tous les jours ils creux mais
qu'est ce que ça change après tout le
temps dont en tout cas je suis la seule
tête de liste sortante c'est vrai aussi
que ce bilan corps que je me le gagner
évidemment que je le porte
il est évident quand on est élu dans la
majorité pendant onze ans et demi
ce serait ça serait stupide de dire je
ne porte pas par contre je reprends
aussi ma liberté je suis quelqu'un
d'extrêmement et loyal je les ai souvent
dit je les dis leur demande
internationaux dernier conseil la
omettre septembre c'est vrai que moi
dans la loyauté quand j'étais pas
d'accord je le talent est pas sur la
place publique
il y avait quelques petits points de
désaccord donc je reprends ma liberté et
c'est là où le premier programme risque
de surprendre un petit peu j'en donnerai
un peu plus de détails au mois de
janvier mais par une quelques points de
ce programme tout de même la sécurité
peut être vous l'avez d'ores et déjà
annoncé vidéoprotection bien évidemment
la sécurité que j'ai porté pendant cinq
ans et demi bien évidemment c'était déjà
arrêté par exactement ça ma délégation
ça s'est arrêté comme un couperet bien
évidemment je n'ai pas terminé ce que je
voulais faire et que ce sera une de mes
priorités de nous pourrir une priorité
pour le mandat suivant
après il y en a bien d'autres vous savez
quand ils frisent ce qui est important
pour les électeurs
c'est que chaque électeur chaque
électeur se retrouve dans le programme
qu'on va porter tous les sujets sont
importants la sécurité bien évidemment
l'environnement
tout le monde parle de l'environnement
mais bien évidemment nous on a on a un
bilan très positif sur l'environnement
la vie de preuves extrêmement positif
zéro phyto de bio à la cantine
j'ai pas tout citer mais donc bien
évidemment ces sujets là vont rester
très important mais ce que nous
souhaitons dans notre liste c'est que
chaque vitre rosien qui va lire notre
programme se dira j'ai pas été oublié et
je suis dedans c'est ça notre objectif
donc des fois ça pète sur des petites
choses
donc rien ne sera oublié personne ne
sera oublié c'est ça l'essentiel
aujourd'hui le programme se construit
encore vous avez plusieurs réunions à
thématique pour recevoir recueillir les
propositions les remarques mais tout à
fait alors on a fait on a une semaine
très chargée la semaine dernière ce
qu'on a fait cinq réunions 5 plutôt
ateliers publics de quartier on s'est
déplacé dans chaque quartier pour
justement recueillir les avis les
retours de la population mais dans les
quartiers
donc ça concernait déjà concerné des
idées à la fois général et de leur
quartier ça c'est important pour nous
qu'on se déplace vers chez des électeurs
vers chez les administrés et ce qui
était très intéressant on a été très
agrément surpris de voir que des retours
que les personnes ne faisait et
répondait complètement à notre programme
répondait à leurs attentes et que du
coup
et plutôt c'est pas confiant parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de travail à faire
d'information et de communication mais
les retours qu'on en a eu
on s'est dit les attentes des villes
prodia on est sur la bonne voie ça
correspond pas mal aux attentes qu'ils
ont dans notre programme ils vont ils
vont s'y retrouver qu'elle est là tant
que la plus forte qui s'est exprimée
selon vous jusqu'à présent à l'orgue à
la sécurité qui ressort bien évidemment
c'est des sujets très généraux au niveau
national finalement la sécurité est
puisée dans le cadre de vie et là on
peut mettre beaucoup de choses dedans
c'est la famille c'est cadre de vie ça
des enveloppes beaucoup de choses et en
fait on retrouve beaucoup beaucoup ce
côté je vais être bien chez moi je vais
être bien dans ma ville c'est ce qu'on
retrouve de plus en plus et notamment à
villepreux qui comme une ville à la
campagne
bien évidemment cet aspect partie de
notre adn est en tout cas en tant qu'élu
gelé depuis longtemps ça je le prendrais
longtemps vie à la campagne qui a
rejoint néanmoins une agglomération
celle de saint quentin en yvelines au
cours du mandat qui vient de s'écouler
quel regard vous portez sur cette
intégration au sein de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et quelles
attentes vous pouvez avoir parce que la
campagne se joue partie aussi l'un
puisque on le rappelle une nouvelle fois
les électeurs vont désigner leurs élus
leurs mères pour le conseil municipal
mais aussi les élus qui vont siéger au
sein d'une agglomération donc il y aura
ensuite à des projets à porter au sein
des agglomérations quel regard vous
faites sur l'intégration jusqu'à présent
et puis quelle attente vous pouvez avoir
pour la suite alors beaucoup de choses
ont avancé ce qu'on est rentrée à saint
quentin en yvelines en janvier 2016 donc
ça fait déjà quelques années
c'est vrai que ça n'a pas été simple au
départ mais il faut pas se mentir on a
on est à paris pendant très longtemps
comme les rentrants condé entrant les
nouveaux entrants c'est beaucoup moins
le cas aujourd'hui
il ya encore beaucoup de travail à faire
j'ai défendues depuis le mois de
septembre le fait que j'ai une
délégation au sein de saint quentin en
yvelines parce que 1000 protée quasiment
pu représenter et ça c'était juste pas
possible pour moi donc je ce que je
souhaite c'est ta mère une mère
extrêmement présente au niveau de saint
quentin en yvelines beaucoup de choses
sont décidés et qui ont aligné avec la
vie au quotidien des habitants de plus
en plus de délégation de pouvoir si
jamais vous avez quelque chose là-dessus
ce fut assez
sceptique aussi sceptique et des fois un
peu à peu inquiète je pense que saint
quentin en yvelines et non de façon
globale les intercommunalités ne doivent
pas prendre trop de compétences à mon
avis il y en a certaines qui pourraient
être enlevés il ya des compétences
facultatives
il faut faire attention et je pense
qu'on aura le temps de reparler de tout
ça je sais que vous allez organiser un
débat je pense que ça va être
intéressant
moi je tendance à dire qu'il faut
peut-être un peu freiné les compétences
à tout-va l'interco je pense que c'est
pas une très bonne idée et qu'il faut
que les maires gardent leurs compétences
principales et même d'autres
chez eux et soient maîtres de leurs de
leur commune
donc là dessus un peu plus critique
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau est
sylvie ce vin montel candidate donc tous
pour villepreux opposé dans ce scrutin
sur sept communes notamment à une liste
porté par le modem et les rues m
l'ancien maire éventuellement alors vous
nous disiez peut-être pas tête à tête de
liste mais voilà et puis également
marie-valérie bain dont nous avons déjà
parlé sur cette antenne l'ensemble des
candidats et qui sont à déclarer auprès
de la préfecture seront bien évidemment
convient un débat vous l'avez évoqué l
ce sera au courant du mois de février
merci à vous